hey everyone and welcome to ET live I'm
Liana Galera coming to you live from
Comic Con right now with the cast of
ghosted hi guys how's it going
thank you so much for stopping by the ET
suite I really appreciate it I am so
excited ghosted is a new comedy coming
to fall this year
give me your ghoulishly good pitch for
what this show is all about well it's a
buddy action comedy with Craig and I is
to sort of outsiders and we're drafted
into this place called the bureau
underground which is a government agency
that deals in the paranormal anything
outside the scientific realm which means
aliens ghosts the undead whatever it's
all under the purview of the bureau
underground and were drafted by them the
agency being run by a Lee's character
love fray and we are drafted to be
agents at this place and we don't know
why we're there or why they picked us
but we're going for it and because both
of us in our regular lives are kind of
like down on our luck we're at low
points in our lives I was a former cop
I'm Emma former cop and now I'm a
security mall guard and Adam is a former
Astro like a professor at Stanford then
I'm disgraced because of my belief in
the paranormal and I claim my wife was
abducted by aliens and so everyone just
thinks I'm insane
so now I work in a bookstore and so
that's where they find us when when when
Ellie recruits us recruit being a kind
word I actually kidnap them so that's
right in the very famous footsteps of
another Fox paranormal duo I got to know
who's got more chemistry you guys are
Mulder and Scully
these guys we have a will they or won't
they buy them yeah that'll be going
through our mess
[Laughter]
to a spooky speed round of questions
guys have you ever had a paranormal
encounter yes no no Craig please
elaborate hmm please elaborate I thought
okay no we go on to the next question um
do you believe in ghosts
yes no which Hollywood actor is most
likely an alien in disguise Donald Trump
oh I'd have to go without him on that uh
who else is deepest I mean I'm gonna go
with both of them I agree I just agree
that's me he's good if you could haunt a
previous horse car who would it be and
why kanta former co-star yeah a former
co-star well I'm gonna when you say
Audrey Plaza because she deserves to be
scared I'm not gonna elaborate any
further than that deserves it yeah I'm
gonna say Robert Davi because he's just
a funny bizarre guy okay uh Kevin Spacey
just see what he's up to now you guys
ghosted is also a term for when you're
dating someone and then just completely
stop responding to you how many people
here are guilty of ghosting someone I
may have I may have gone sued somebody
deserted Oh gentlemen I am a gentleman
but I mean you can't go late well I hate
that that's so rude do you you know last
time I was in like the dating pool the
word ghosted hadn't even been in well
it's so nice to see you guys in a comedy
together because you most recently were
both in more dramatic roles Craig I
loved you on mr. robot thank you and
Adam it was so great seeing you on big
little lies why is it so much fun to go
into those dramatic roots but always
have comedy to come back to
well you know when you're driving to
work and it's a dramatic show like big
little eyes or Ali and I actually did a
show called tell me you love me like 10
years ago that was very very serious
you're driving to work kind of thinking
about like how am I gonna I gotta figure
out I'm gonna cry today like hell you
gotta get into that space and it's a
it's a lot to kind of think about and
feel and everything whereas when I'm on
my way to ghost it it all I have to
think about is trying not to laugh so
while we're speaking it make a little
lies season 2 would you be down - of
course I mean you know but you don't
bring your question co-stars I don't
know I don't know if that's ever and of
course they're there we're in his
contract have you talked to your
on-screen wife wife Reese about her Emmy
nomination I texted congratulations yes
of course what do you want future
ghosted fans to know about the show
before they tune in it's really really
funny but it's kind of scary too and I
think you're gonna like it yeah it is
comin on good spooks oh hopefully you
won't get spooked by it yes we're hoping
yes it's good it's exciting it's like
you know like if stranger things at
Midnight Run had a baby
ghost stranger run on set yeah um
no Craig scares very yeah yeah I don't
do ahead and my hand and I slammed the
hand into the wall that was scary yeah I
got hurt Allah said that actually you
were actually in real pain we there's a
human head that gets thrown around in
the pilot spoiler alert heavy hair and
it and it really it actually injured
Craig's finger at one point finger in a
weird spot catch the head agree to
disagree
in a spicy way we're gonna find out when
we tune into the premiere of ghosts on
October 1st guys thank you so much for
stopping by thank you fans for tuning in
right now we are gonna be live to you
from comic-con all weekend long with the
cast of your favorite shows so stick
with us like subscribe comment all that
good stuff bye